Well. Jay and. All of a gentle of a man. And i became involved with the nimbin adventure. When it's early.
And it's nice in stages in sydney when people were beginning to talk about a new.
New form of festival for university and other students.
And i was involved with a mad mob of people who believed that we had in suzy as in spirit an adventure to do things
differently and i guess we really are certain i believe that we really could. Bring about social change.
That would make for a better world for us so was and for. The various offspring that were beginning to appear.
Around their fate at the time and it was a very exciting time for me.
And i still hold a lot of that excitement i still hold a lot a lot of that idealism.
And i'm at now apologize apologies. On that no apologies for being a nimbin hippie.
Ok i live by the bitch bar and i you know. But i am a hippie doughton true. You know. Whatever the expression is.
And i've had a lot of enjoyment. And a lot of learning from those times too in there.
People often say have you got any regrets about the time you spent at noon then i think regretted smart girl.
Nancy asking a question like that i think it's.
It's been a wonderful social experiment it is a wonderful social experiment and i really believe that.
Although lots of the things that we thought my occur.
And some of the social change that we thought my occur
and be more far reaching throughout a strike iran indeed the world.
Even though those things some of those things haven't occurred. I still believe that humans are.
Very influential santa.
And what he does does formulate a lot of creative china on this north coast area
and throughout the east coast of new south wales. Memories of the festival. Memories of the system a beautiful place.
Magnificent weather center tested. Hundreds of little farm was not campsites not spread throughout the valley.
Just directly behind him then it really felt quite tribal. It was very gentle. Wonderful into china's and.
Creative people that were brought in specifically for the festival.
And a lot of wonderful discussions and ideas it was a very a lot of talk
and i mean you could spin from twenty four hours a day. Discussing interesting.
Things with a number of different people. It was very very much of the image of long and. Far out folk.
With women in long dresses and by visit their breasts and things like that.
And of course that's something that i like to talk about lighter. Of demise.
For me it was amazing just to be able to to live out in a beautiful country saudi area.
With so many wonderful people i mean i think there's something like i thousand people so the estimates
and guesstimates of the numbers who came through the system it was certainly a lot for a little term like newman i mean
the streets were just chock a block with people you can barely get a vehicle. Down the the streets.
Are in the silly pretty. Walking between the tomato sauce. And the nimbin pub. Juggling. Burning sticks.
On the top rope that that that was from a part of the problem by the pole viral no this sort of thing.
Dollar brand playing amazing far out. In the jazz piano in the nimbin hole and. I meant.
Philip to take the guy riding his unicycle through the streets of nimbin and towards the showground.
The hari krishna is wandering around singing in the sleigh for hours providing amazing meals. And then.
The hari krishna is being followed by a group of sort of. Far out hippies with gambits going.
Everybody tolerating everybody i mean it really pushed a lot of people's buttons in terms of toleration.
I remember the police attempting to arrest people for drugs. Which always seemed to me from my.
Very close proximity to the event that it was a planned. And by simply the people. Said no. We will control the.
People are not dealing drugs it is not a drugs. And just by sickly.
Issuing the police releasing the people who were arrested.
Or who had been apprehended they weren't arrested and was a very powerful tahn that why.
There was the learning unit where people would put up. Interesting areas that.
On a blackboard that they were interested in discussing. Giving a seminar on a whatever. And it was a very long time.
Lots of wonderful music here there and everywhere and we went to a way out extended family group. From the city.
We had set up a.
Area where we had a communal far communal kitchen
and all our tents all around so any time you want to do a little bit of some comfort you could just want.
There and then be anything from you know. Half a dozen people to maybe thirty at meal time.
Around and basically for many of us who had been rising nuclear families post world war two nuclear families.
And some of us of course it had the experience of living communally that to live in this big.
Expanded family will travel for them it was just wonderful. And it really did.
Did show that people can live together harmoniously and happily and creatively and exotic. Sadly.
It was surely for a short period of time and. Everybody's on good behavior.
On the base the high returns like that but it was a really hopeful time. Due to fool of a name is a t.p.s.
Covered in fat cat from the fields. People wandering around with video cameras and type recorders.
I often wonder what happened to those uk us. Local shopkeepers and local townsfolk who had been very carefully and.
Continually consulted about this process.
I had no idea what that would what we had no idea what we were in for when we started setting it up.
But i was sort of slightly shocked and bemused most of the time incredibly tolerant.
Dieties cafe daisy stuart his somebody. I would hope you have talked with and.
Was one of those examples of she told us. The smiths.
Molly smith molly and tom smith used to live on the one street in town millions myth about.
Molly and tom about did now. That spirit charter's mother and father. And the child is still in town.
With their daughter and running they had was to.
Molly smith and tom smith sitting right in the middle of it their little bent. Is right in the.
The entrance to their once shop now. Then house.
Which is now than in the new gallery known in second hand goods gallery.
That would sit there and i would say things like.
He wants to say this is the best color television in the whole of the world. And i sincerely believed it.
And i went they were happy. I mean a lot of they all thomas as. That were cold. Although bemused shocked.
Scared or whatever we're really delighted to see the. Darling tan. Re. Generating. You know.
So many of those old people's i had seen. Many of their children.
Where they've ended grandchildren moved away from the area because there's nothing holding them in nimbin it was a
daunting rundown. Falling to pieces all wooden buildings town very quiet for the. But to say any.
Teenage kids living there was lucky. There.
And so to say this new energy coming a lot i had no idea what it was about a way it was heading.
Really quite supportive. Because i could remember.
For example where we lived in paradise valley where we have entry we bought land just before the festival.
At the end of craft and rode on the blue no where we live we were the last people along the road.
Now that they were where we believe. Many years ago. Twenty italian families beyond us. Into the valley living.
So the number had seen very populated towns
and then people had wandered away again it was a big part of the dairy industry and a lot of the modeling industry.
We were the new push for sure. And we was probably in many ways as. Many of us was disrespectful as any modern to push.
When there isn't. Another word as we were very respectful. I was really happy to be associated with people.
Paradise valley and.
That was my extended family for many many years and many of those people still are extended family.
Because we always we made a policy of really informing people about what we were about we felt that information was
part of our political ideology that if you have full information then you. You don't get into trouble.
Because if everybody has the full information people afraid to make decisions.
With full information so we decided almost as a policy it was not written policy
or anything like that that we would tell all and i was in local to about who we were and what we were bad.
And we found that bottling asos up. To people like that they were very welcoming totally supportive of us i mean.
The generosity that we received when we first moved to the area was it was almost embarrassing committees and we go
and visit our next door neighbor's lawn dudley harris. You know. Tardily room. You know.
Hippies from the city come to sort of. You know. Survival mode where the typical. Image. And i would give this.
We would walk away with docks and trucks and fresh vegetables from the gardens and preserve and jans and i mean it was.
Was really embarrassing and what could you give these people back i mean you know i raised my first crop of beans.
You know this very exhausted lee and sort of. Was it really appropriate to take them down to somebody.
Not just brains but sort of day. And things like that.
You know and other others all sorts of funny stories come to my mind you know real in the style to stuff like.
Tell about the truck. That you're ok so we decided to raise chooks. Because we wanted to have fresh eggs.
Free range fresh eggs. Chooks to wait.
So we acquired from charlie soured who was the local tip man who's quite a character. You've encountered.
Who was the truck. King by sickly of. The whole region. And we acquired five trucks and.
At that stage we had no record to drive up to a humble dwelling.
So we had to walk up a very steep hill across the creek and off a very steep hill.
And in the haze of summer john and i carried in his bags these chucks you know very close to put trucks in his eyes
but what about them you know. We carried them up the hill and finally got them up there.
And we liberated them into the newly created. Trippin.
With beautiful he touches like you know gold bowls and things like that.
Run those signs out of the door you know i mean we really wanted welcome at us. One of them.
Had god what do you do with the truck.
Well this truck was perfectly all right before we had begun our since i trudged over to
and i was with you know probably that quote of an ad.
But there was something like this it's what do i do with the truck that's dead
and she said well it's alright your pockets. Yes i know but how do you apply.
So she sort of told me how you plucked it and so i then tried to back up the hill and five. Q ok.
With pliers we're playing. It's failing health. It's york. I'm thinking. This is a self sufficient.
She had a missing to tell me that you plan to choke him a lot more.
Assume that i quit this by sixty so eventually i think i'd gone back to ask her again
and so i learned that yes your plans that you can cause
and poured boiling hot water for too long so by the time this feathers were plucked out this chick was killing
and back and then you know had to gothe it which was something i hadn't encountered before.
I mean i can remember john and i laughing hilariously at the top. But also there was a slight element of despair.
So we were very wrong. But very very enthusiastic and we were quite determined that we were going to get.
When it is cut that well i said about it.
With a had thomas living in him than being a hippie and i can come united mean. Of course there were hard times.
It's funny how things were you know like you tend to repress the unpleasant memories i don't think i've done that i
think i just put them into a different kind of perspective. Perhaps we lived communally and the household that.
Harry invests in john and i build the kind the communal household.
And many more and as people built their houses many of them.
Used back each in an bathroom as the kitchen and bathroom all the rest everything there and it was really that.
The communities. One house. So many. Everybody would pass. In and out of it and. It was nothing for us to have.
Twenty people to dinner. It was a frequent event. And that was a very happy event. But it was also a very.
Energy consuming event. We had lots of kids. We had a very good ratio of adults to keep.
That is we had many more adults to kids. Very healthy rich. Relationship i think. In that it meant they were usually.
Every kid always had some adult. Happy to be available to them.
You might be getting on particularly well with your mom. Well you just could avoid.
And go and spend some time with somebody else who. Welcome you with open eyes. So the kids had a good time of it.
And i think we our law think i did too that the had tons will. Working at the spot stresses and the difficulties.
We were very functional i think in terms of avoiding the sorts of stresses a lot of.
Shared households or communal households often encounter. I mean we just had god laws you know.
Wasn't a rule it was just how we accepted. Each other's laws and how it come to live together at the minute.
And that was because we lived together in a city many of us before that.
You didn't leave the washing up on the sink things like that so you never. We just had that is sort of dice.
So we never had that kind of stress so it was a it was a great spirit of generosity with the people that are if we
didn't. And that spirit of generosity was very important. Spirit of generosity towards each other as adults.
Spirit of generosity towards each other's kids. Spirit of generosity towards each other's friends and relatives.
Some of the hard times i think when they were not having enough space to take my space away. My privacy.
And i don't necessarily think that's anybody else's fault of of my own for not wanting to.
I don't want to miss out on any of the action in a way and none of us did.
We had lots of issues to work out of that around money. What sequel. Some of us went out to work.
In philly holly paid jobs others others of us were staying home and building.
Being the home people where is the equity there. We never really fully address those issues.
And i was unfairly had tons. When relationships. Also than many of them. Broke up.
Which is not an on an unusual event for any body in the series oh now even of course you know if you're in a personal
relationship it was in cross of course that affected everybody else and i were some very difficult times for us as.
Community members. It was hard building you know.
Physically getting out there and building fences and bridges and have.
From by a lot of people who bicycling the academics. I think we were academics and continued.
Well that we had a sort of activities that we did many of us have continued to the that sort of.
Lawn that were there originally. So yeah they were had time. There was some very hated.
Times around how do you discipline children. And that was a very interesting thing although it was hard at times.
It was a very again the spirit of generosity was there and.
A lot of people found it difficult to have a logical parent for example. Interact with a young child. In the distant.
Disciplinary or limit setting talk of why.
And i'm not think i learned very quickly i've had the privilege of living with young children before i had my own.
And so i had been in that role of being prepared to be committed to children in that way of setting limits.
Because it is a commitment to be prepared to go through the thick and the thin not just.
If we can in not just being nice friends all the time.
So the time my kids came along i was more experience with that but. To to watch somebody else.
Disciplining old setting limits with your own child which my be a raging battle between i struck a four year old
and a fairly adamant. Adult and trust that process and does to people have a commitment.
Particularly adult to the child commitment. Kids never had any difficulty.
Committing themselves to anybody that would love them. But to watch that.
And now that they had it was so committed to the child that. Even if that were in the eye.
Stressful situation that they would with their own spice. Tom.
Come back to being with that child seeing that child on the in a loving that child
and coming back to the loving relationship. And letting what had passed. Be passed.
So that was all that could be seen as difficult as some about this growing times.
And in light is some people who came to the community with all the children who hadn't had that experience of having
the kids commune. Children from very from birth or from very early on i think found that very difficult.
And i found that more stressful than anything that ever occurred to me with my kids.
And it's really interesting to see has social conditioning. Gets laid down very easily. And very early.
Like i think john has a very good example. And so he's a very good example of kids who were commune kids and.
Really assume that any adults that were around were available to them.
I really would kids who went through that now i want mommy to get me the sort of. Spies. If there was an adult.
Oh at all a pair of legs by sickly around. Who can provide for them that particular night i would ask court and.
So some of those difficulties of people working at their relationships to children
and things like that might have been difficulties but the.
The long term effect was a very positive and a very healthy one adelaide.
Well so may i was prepared to put pretty well everything up for grabs. Theoretically anyway.
And i think it's taken me a long time to even consider some of the areas that i didn't think you needed analysis at the
time and still do. Yeah. And just being. Always an urban dweller. All of my life.
And to move to the country was a very expensive experience for me it is the spice the freedom that that guy. Me.
I could decide what to the old where ever a lot. That was fantastic. So.
On those sorts of physical parameters it was very new
and i could make up anything i wanted to i wanted to build a large house that sort of had separate units too it was
sort of connected by walkways and lots of people could happily ever after live in it. So i decided to do it.
You know i mean i was sort of fairly fearless in that way i thought because will do it.
Now when we went to council
and said that these are all building plans you know we're doing it the right way we're doing it by the letter of the
lore and all that something i don't know you can't do that and i said well we're going to. You know i mean i was.
I wasn't being. Brash or nasty always just. But you know that's what i'm going to do it.
Did you know mark and i saw him in the health inspector wally doctoring.
It was a real problem to him so i learned very quickly.
This man is very good at creating problems perhaps the best thing i can do is offer him the opportunity to solve a
problem for me. So we presented it in that way and. After many many weeks of dollar.
Negotiation he told us that we could actually do exactly what we had on paper. If we called it something else.
And so we had this thing called most special residency. Occupancy buildings. Shrub's is that i've become.
Thank you very much mr crean we said you know very politely we went away and. What we wanted to do. We thought we were.
Well i was new to to create an extended family. Most of us had come from what we consider to be dysfunctional families.
But. Or are there considered to be dysfunctional families and.
We really felt that we could probably do it better together. I didn't seem that difficult a task.
To live with people with gentle spirit generosity and to love each other to lock each other to love each other's kids.
And to give kids the opportunity. Instead of having to be locked in that.
Mom dad or mom just dad or just mama whatever you know sort of. The nuclear family even it was a single parent.
Nuclear family rather than being locked in that. To be giving our kids the opportunity to have a much broader.
Scope of people to choose their relationships from and to form their own form than their own selves from.
You know i mean i was really quite happy to have and still them. To have any adults. Put in input. To the kids.
And i figured that i'd like the.
Intelligent choices along the way as to which were the best bits of everybody or everybody's attitudes and.
As a result but probably come out to be really wonderful people. That's true. But i would i add to that question.
Thriving. How can i pick you up on that. The statement was that it put a lot of strain on relationships.
I don't know that that's true. I think living.
Successfully with any and partner is quite an energy and emotion consuming experience. All of the lot.
From those times. Because i not only was in a relationship.
But out had the opportunity to view it very close quarters either and i should ships.
It's true that many of those relationships most of those relationships no longer exist. But.
Is that statistically different from anywhere else that. You know.
I don't think it is it's not my observation i can remember reading statistics in the seventy's with.
From the north coast area. Which i think. Said that sixty percent of school students.
Think it was early ha school student. Hostel students. Sixty percent of the students kind from separated families.
Now that was at the top on that was from the whole area this wasn't just me
but that was at the time where it was still considered. We've had a marital breakdown.
Or your relationships and it having do you from your from a separated family i you know you poor dear.
You know that kind of attitude was still prevalent. Even the statistics were. To the contrary.
And i can remember i think kerry coming home with that statistic of us discussing it
and having a good ol chuckle knowing that. You know we had many friends and so.
Who were in that category that we were actually in a majority as distinct from monarchy when. Once that because.
So the actual question. Did it put a strain on relationships. Of course it put a strain. And a strain that.
Nuclear families don't have. But it also contributed so much more to us as individuals.
And you know why i think it gave many of us the freedom to move apart from each other
and still try out he was brought to try to maintain civil friendly relationships. You know.
Live with somebody for many many. And then just suddenly stop. And if you. If you.
Born children with somebody you presumably. I mean assuming everybody is fairly. Thoughtful about their choices.
You probably don't have kids with somebody who thinks an absolute idiot.
Well then she will not say you know you actually have some regard and love that person at some stage along the way.
And if that.
No longer is happening it doesn't mean that you don't have to height that not have regard and respect for that person.
So i and i have and i have been a contributing factor. I don't think so and contributing factor in relationships.
Ending.
But i think i was the opportunity to then go on
and have respect for life in ships with their former partners who were often the parents of their children.
Polygamy of this is monogamy. With with those issues of a result.
Yes the add to that that's a yes and i think for some individuals. We've been able to come to.
I mean some may for example i have a fairly clear attitude about my that my stance on that for others is i don't know
whether that ever resolve the mill whether it's even a problem.
We certainly talked about to talk about incest within the not insist. Was it.
Not insist that's another issue to talk about. Which was certainly.
We certainly encountered as some of us had relationships with each other at sort of a primary couple in.
And most of us were primarily coupled on the outside. And that created havoc.
And so there was an agreement that that we would not do that.
This is i'm talking about just at paradise valley i mean there are plenty of other situations where people have done
that they just cause too much stress. And too much lack of trust and breaking down.
Too many of the good things that occurred. And some people never recovered.
Never recovered on i think from some of those events that were too great and were that we didn't.
We talked a lot about that i mean. I think my attitude has always been on the great. Emma goldman.
Said
and emma goldman was a feminist american three minutes from the early to the century right before that in a century
and into. Ids. And she believed in free love.
And people used to say you know hippies and free love and i mean i think i do believe in free love
but i'd like to have the other side what i mean by that. And by that on main.
I think people should be free to love
and have intimate relationships including sexually intimate relationships with anybody that they truly love.
As long as it isn't hurtful to anybody else. And if that. If that relationship is no longer truly loving.
That's presumably appropriate for that kind of intimacy to china. And if that person. Then. Forms another.
Really close bond with somebody else. Then i should be free to be i would exercise that.
Leave that relationship to its full flowering. If it. Which my also include. Which might include sexual intimacy.
So that's what i mean by free love. I don't really have any attachment to.
People staying together for the kids for example. I don't think that. Free love.
Means that you don't make those choices without a great deal of thought. Care and consideration. Building my own.
Lot to tell you my. I'd started off my university career as an academic student.
And i decided i didn't want to be a designer of. Ticky tacky little boxes and.
Not be putting kinko grey color schemes rather than blue and brown into government.
Toilets and things like that i mean. I was in i was right in the year over woodson.
And i realize the mess i was spectacular i would just be a very ordinary architect.
I didn't think i was really spectacular in the architecture field.
So i decided not to continue with architecture so i decided i'd really like to be a capital.
And i went along and applied to do carpentry and joinery. Through the type system.
And was told that there weren't enough toilets. Which i didn't exactly understand.
His part of that story is that i thought i was missed. I thought.
I thought i was mrs watson coming along for my dutch speaking husband who couldn't understand english.
When it became clear that i was actually jack all of a.
And i wanted to do it happened to be enjoyed and then i found out that they were not enough toilets. In the college.
And i didn't really think that this particular bureaucratic problem had much to do with me
and then i realised what the message was that we don't want. Women girls doing acca to doing. Catherine jointly.
We don't want girls doing. Happen to enjoy so i sort of.
That was good outcome and i very sheepishly sort of crawled away from that.
So i guess you could say that i had this deep seated desire.
To be involved with the audience from a very early age and.
When i moved to the country was an opportunity to fulfill that.
I went into industrial design after that and psychiatric nursing and all sorts of things.
But when i moved to the country he was my opportunity to become involved in buildings.
So i was very passionately and closely involved with the buildings of office building. And the first house.
Which was a large extended hass. And i found it very tarring and almost impossible to build physically.
While i was pregnant with cell. I suffered a great deal of. Twenty father. Morning north. Surely a mile to him.
And i did a lot of the organization a lot of decision making but i didn't do much hands on stuff.
When sally and john his dad. John and i decided to separate and.
Move further apart from each other the obvious solution kind to me. And that was that i should build my own spice.
And i can relate to the current communal house still.
As long as we had our own spices we were good co-parent the kids underneath the sign sort of under the side hochman.
But you know. But anyway. And so i decided to go myself a half so i may have to go to the family.
But that's what i was going to do and everybody went. Ok. So i did. And i set myself a time limit.
I decided i would build a house in twelve months working three days a week. Which meant. I needed to arrange.
You know three days child free taught to do that so i did.
So it was interesting for me because lots of issues were involved.
It was me as a young mother beginning to negotiate child free tom.
Although we were very committed to the notion of us all being equal. I was discovering that once you had children.
A lot of those ideas sort of slipped out the door a bit.
It was one of the issues for me that i wanted to have that in that respect of the quality.